hello all and welcome to dev 302
building and managing graphql apis i'm
dave foyer and i'm joined by greg
braille we're a part of the apogee team
and we're super excited to present this
to you today
hey i'm greg i'm also part of the apogee
team and i'm also excited
i guess the first thing i want to get
out of the way is that you know
sometimes in technology we can over
emphasize how new technologies and
exciting ideas are uh are dominant in
the conversation and so i just want to
be clear and i think both greg and i
share that you know rest is still the
king of apis if you look at this graph
which is from google trends it clearly
shows that rest is still the king of
apis and still dominates interest and so
while we're here to talk to you about
graphql and some other api styles it's
important that we realize that rest
still has a very important and very
prominent position in building and
designing apis for the future
if we're going to contrast graphql and
rest apis i think there's three specific
areas that we'd want to talk to you
about the first is that both graphql and
rest offer a consistent way to access
different types of data so while graphql
and rest construct things differently
and construct requests differently and
get responses differently fundamentally
they both allow you to access data
graphql offers a query language that's
different of course than the rest query
style and that can potentially work
across many types of backends but
fundamentally they're both requesting
data and they're both offering a
consistent a consistent access pattern
for the data the second is efficiency
while it's possible to construct rest
apis in an efficient way graphql is
specifically built to avoid overfetching
or under fetching data the query
language is super powerful and allows
you to request just the data you need
for your client whether it's a mobile
client a web client or another style of
application
and the last is implementation
complexity
implementing an http server to parse
urls and return data from a variety of
sources that's a straightforward task
and many people do that in their
environments today but graphql requires
specific software and a specific engine
on the server side that can parse the
queries and break them down into
execution steps and so that's a
significant difference between graphql
and rest
to recap some of the benefits of graphql
you know i think data load control and
granularity are super important the fact
that graphql has a single endpoint and
allows you to really execute one request
and then have the fan out on the
southbound side make a whole bunch of
subsequent requests and return that it's
very very powerful it also means that if
one resolver fails other queries can
still succeed and still resolve and
bring back useful data in the rest world
rest doesn't necessarily work that way
rest has multiple different endpoints
and so each query to each endpoint has
to be treated individually
so could you maybe talk a little bit
about as as a software engineer maybe
i'm building an app why would i choose
graphql
and why would i choose rust
you know greg great question i think
there's a lot of apps specifically apps
built using the react.js framework that
really benefit from the fact that
graphql will only get the data that's in
view so that for instance if you are
tracking sports statistics you only
retrieve the sports statistics for the
player that you're looking at or you
only receive the sports statistics for
the specific table that you can view in
a mobile app as opposed to rest which
might require additional apis or
additional parameters to accommodate all
the different views that might exist in
an app and create individual apis for
those different views so being able to
leverage the graphql query language to
really only get the data that you need
for that specific user creates a certain
amount of efficiency and a certain
amount of developer safety where they
know they're getting the data that they
expect when they expect it versus having
to make multiple calls in order to fill
out whatever the whatever table the user
might choose to view in that application
does that make sense yeah so with rest
i'm used to using an api gateway like
apogee where i might
have a couple of customized versions of
my api for different devices because i
want to have
um it be more efficient are you saying
with graphql i have i have more options
i have more flexibility in the data that
i return to my client absolutely along
with the control that gives you the
ability to request exactly what you want
and retrieve exactly the data you want
also comes a tremendous amount of
responsibility right suddenly you have
to figure out upfront what data you want
versus simply calling an api uh that
being said with that control comes a
certain amount of developer safety as we
said where calling that one api just
becomes very simple and very easy and
that query language is really what
provides that control and the rest in
the graphql world so a mobile developer
might really like the fact that they can
choose exactly what they want send one
request to the server and get it all
back at once rather than having to
navigate a whole forest of individual
urls in order to get the same
information
absolutely yeah that's a great point
greg you know the third point is that
whereas in the past graphql required a
whole bunch of specific glue in order to
work with different programming
languages and different frameworks we're
really seeing a proliferation of graphql
client libraries so graphql really is
available as a polyglot uh protocol and
is no longer simply uh reduced to a few
languages or a few frameworks graphql is
really fairly open and and and really
portable and so we're seeing a a a
change a shift in adoption of graphql as
a result of that
so
you know i think if we take a step back
we'll see that there are really two
communities of use for apis there are
api programs which are tight-knit teams
where the client server are tight-knit
group or sometimes they're the same
person that's developing both the server
application and the client application
and then there are developer programs
which are really about creating apis as
products and exposing those apis to
those different communities so that
different developers can build their own
front ends of their own application
servers that leverage your apis to
create different value propositions so
in that specific instance it could be a
different business unit it could be a
different company it could be a partner
but you no longer have the same scope of
control over both the server and the
client and that's a significant uh
that's a significant change but that's a
significant difference between api
programs and development programs that
on api programs you really don't have to
be as strict about design of your api
because since you control the client and
the server you can sort of
assume a certain amount of knowledge and
mediate between that on your own but
when you have a developer program the
clients don't know what you know and so
you have to make sure to actually
productize your api in such a way that
makes it discoverable and accessible and
makes it easy for developers to leverage
and consume that api
in order to drive business value not
just for you but also for their
application
so if if i'm using graphql
how do i know a developer is not gonna
do something crazy and and query a bunch
of data that i'm supposed to get
exactly greg perfect setup i think
that's the fundamental challenge is that
we don't we don't know what clients are
going to do in rest we know what apis we
expose and so we know what clients are
going to request because that's what the
api is the api exposes that resource
in graphql when you're exposing all of
your resources like a graph clients can
really request whatever they want and so
we're seeing graphql struggling in that
area in the area of developer programs
where it's been super popular with api
programs and i think what we're doing
with apogee is super exciting here in
taking all the learnings that we've had
from productization of apis and bringing
them over to graphql greg why don't you
talk a little bit about api
productization and how we're bringing
that to graphql
awesome thanks
so if we look at this chart this talks
about a lot of the things that a
an api team needs to think about when
they're trying to turn an api into a
product taking something that's just an
http endpoint with some json and turn it
into something that developers from
different organizations and different
companies can consume and a lot of these
things are things that if you've been
following the world of api management or
seen any apogee things before you've
probably heard of about a lot of these
things um time to first hello world for
instance that's what that acronym is for
um is a really important metric for an
api program if you want developers to
adopt your api
having a community having standards like
oauth as part of your api and having
things like developer portals and this
enables really the one of the most
important things that's a difference
between an api used by a small team and
a developer program used by lots of
developers in different organizations
is the ability to do self-service and
when we talk about api productization a
big part of it is self-service
how does a developer who wants to use
your api find out about the api figure
out what the api does and get
credentials if they can do that in a few
minutes your api is ready for
consumption by almost anyone in the
world and that applies whether your api
is a rest api of the style we've been
talking about for years and years in the
world of api management or a graphql api
now when we talk about this we talk
about control security observability and
governance and in the world of rest apis
we often do a lot of these things based
on the the fundamental principles of
rest like urls and verbs
we'll do things like we'll say
if you've got credentials for the api um
you are authorized to invoke certain
urls but not other urls or perhaps
you're authorized to get all the urls
but if you want to post some of the urls
you need a different kind of of
of of credentials
all of these same things are going to
apply to graphql we're going to ask a
lot of these same questions so when
david talked about making a graphql api
ready for consumption by developers the
developers will love it because now i
can do anything i have access to your
whole schema i can query all kinds of
stuff and i can build a great app and
what i've said for years and years about
this stuff is that it's not just that
you have to worry about an attacker or
someone who's malicious
you also have to worry about people who
just make mistakes right like oh i
didn't realize that by executing that
graphql query i would download 10 000
rows of data from the database and clog
up the internet and make my mobile
device crash
um now i know that so i know i have to
include a parameter but wouldn't it be
nice if we could put some controls in
front of the graphql api so a developer
can't even do that sort of thing by
accident
so what we're doing at apogee
is we're starting on a journey of
figuring out what we need to do
to make graphql apis the same kind of
first class apis
as the rest apis and the other kinds of
apis that apogee traditionally supports
so in the traditional world of api
management we have this chart where we
have api teams build apis developers
build apps for apis
to create user experiences for end users
and
that transition from an api used by an
api team to a developer program is what
this is all about
the question is when we are working with
graphql how does this differ
from the way it looks for a rest api and
the answer is not very much
all of the same principles apply
the developer wants to be able to
discover the api via self service they
want to get credentials
they want to use the api the api team
wants to have control over who's allowed
to use their api and how much they're
allowed to use the api are they allowed
to use different parts of the api for
different purposes is there a quota that
stops them from using the api too much
are there security rules or audit rules
is there even a billing plan associated
with that api
we want to be able to do all of these
things for graphql apis which means that
we have to not only look at urls and
verbs but we have to look at the
structure of the graphql query and we
have to understand when you make a query
what is this query trying to do and as
an api team what kind of things can i
let the developers do and you can do
this by having lots of different graphql
endpoints but one of the advantages of
an api management system is that it
allows the api team to be very
sophisticated in turning those apis into
products so if they want to launch with
an api that does five things and sell it
to customers for a certain price or for
free
but then they want to add two more
things but they only want certain
customers to be able to do those things
and then they want to add one more thing
that only a few customers can see but no
one else should find out about you can
do all of this in your api management
product
without changing your api at all you do
this by restricting an apogee you do
this by creating something an api
something called an api product
and an api product basically specifies
which parts of the api are available to
which kind of consumers what kind of
quotas on them and we can attach
additional data to it that we can use to
make other decisions
we want to do those same sorts of things
with graphql apis
so if you look at what we've added to
apogee
apogee now has a way inside any apogee
proxy to parse a graphql request
first of all just to reject it if it's
invalid or even do schema validation
that can be super valuable because it
means that if you have malicious users
or
developers who are still learning the
api and making mistakes apogee can nip
all of those uh
all of those uh invalid requests you
know right in the apogee proxy and not
even let them get to your backend server
which takes load off your graphql engine
but graphql can but apogee can now parse
that query understand this the
what it's trying to do and make
decisions
so a very simple thing you could do for
instance is say that certain developers
or certain applications are only allowed
to execute queries against the graphql
api
whereas you have to have a different
kind of credential and possibly approval
from the api team in order to make
mutations
which means basically we can very easily
separate the read-only api from the read
write api
and then we can do more and i think what
we're doing in the future is we're
looking at what more we can do
so for instance uh we also now that we
understand the shape of the api we can
put a bunch of information into the
apigee message flow
we can then use other policies to make
other decisions
so it gives a lot of flexibility for you
as a developer right now to build some
interesting
api graphql api related access control
and other decision making logic into
your apogee proxy and it's going to make
it possible for us to do even more with
this in the future
and greg do you see this affecting
how enterprises are able to position
graphql apis for consumption like is
this something that you see helping uh
application developers build new
experiences using graphql apis yeah um
so if you're an application i mean you
know back you know you and i have been
around the world a little while uh once
upon a time um it was considered
terribly bad form to expose your
relational database directly to
developers because developers might be
able to do something like select star
from customers
or worse yet delete star from customers
um and overwhelm the database or execute
some ridiculous query that is nested 17
levels deep and joins you know 12
different tables together and slows down
the application for everybody so that's
where three-tier computing and
transaction processing monitors and all
these things came in
same thing with graphql if you just put
a graphql api in front of your your core
data and give access to developers to
get at it directly
then you have to have some trust in your
developers that they're not going to
execute queries
that cause performance problems or
security problems or compliance problems
so if you have something sitting in
front of that graphql api that's able to
look at the queries and make decisions
about what's allowed and what's not
allowed i think it makes it easier for
an enterprise to be okay with the idea
of using graphql for critical data
awesome
and with that we have a demo you're
going to listen to me and what we're
going to do is we're going to show some
of the new graphql features of apogee
and what we can do with them
i'm going to start with an example of a
mobile application that uses graphql
this application is a product catalog
and it makes one api call to get the
product information plus an api call for
every price and every stock information
so as you can see when i refresh the
screen we have a lot of these blue
circles that show api calls being made
and when i click on an individual
product we make three api calls to get
the result
however i can also switch my application
to take advantage of graphql in that
case it makes one api call to my back
end it's querying the exact same
database tables in my case it's even
calling the exact same grpcs but the
mobile app is sending one request to the
back end and the back end is fanning all
of that and returning one response the
result is quite a bit more responsive
there's only one api call required to
get all the product information i need
when i scroll up and down it's nice and
zippy and there's none of that
refreshing going on so as you can see
graphql can be a very effective way to
make an efficient and snappy mobile app
now that we've looked at the app let's
actually see what's going on with the
api under the covers
underneath of course i have a graphql
api
and i can do some things in this graphql
api like for instance get a list of
products and like in all good graphql
apis i can merge data from different
data sets i can sort i can decide how
many and i can get information about an
individual product and once again i can
decide exactly what fields i want to see
or don't see and in this particular case
this particular graphql query is being
secured via an api key which is being
enforced by apogee
using this particular api key
i can also try and get information about
the price of an item
and if i use that key here's my query to
get the price
you'll see that i get an error this is
coming from apigee because apogee parsed
the query it saw that the top level
selection set was called price and this
particular api key is not allowed to
make that query
however if i change the api key to an
api key that uses a different api
product
i now
can get the price
now that we've seen what the api looks
like let's see how it works in apigee
first of all apigee has always had api
products they're key to api management
because they let you package up an api
without changing the back end into
different combinations of functionality
different quota settings and even
different aspects like security
depending on who's consuming the api
we've added graphql support to api
products so now in addition to filtering
on url paths and verbs like we could
before we can also filter on for
instance the graphql operation type like
whether it's a query or mutation and we
can set different quotas for different
products like we always could so for
instance you could set it up so a
certain api key or a certain set of
applications that use oauth might be
allowed only to do queries or they might
have a different quota than another set
and they might even be restricted based
on the name of the graphql operation
now the way this is enforced is in the
proxy of course
and we have the first part of
functionality to do this is our new
graphql policy first thing it does is
parse the query to make sure it's valid
it can also validate the schema if you'd
like
and then it sets a bunch of variables
that we can use for other things for
instance it's used in the check api key
policy to enforce the api product logic
that i just talked about
i wanted to go a little bit further in
this demo and use the name of the
selection set which is the top of that
query to determine which api keys could
query which parts of my graphql schema
and i did that using some javascript
i set a variable in the product that
specifies what top level selection sets
are allowed
and i used a variable that is set by the
graphql policy which contains that
information
after that a little bit of error
checking follows and some clever but
simple javascript that simply looks to
see if the name of that
selection set is in the product that's
all there is to it and now i'm able to
have some very interesting controls on
my graphql application
so we've just seen a demo
that shows how you can use the new
graphql features of apogee to parse
queries and understand them and have
additional logic to make decisions about
those to make your api more ready for
the enterprise over to you dave
thanks greg that was awesome
we're super excited about graphql and
our ability to bring it to our customers
and prospects to build new apps and
experience with this new technology
please go to cloud.google.com apigee to
try it out we'd love to hear what you
think
thanks for joining us today and have a
great rest of the summit
you